here in the Japanese countryside some of
Japan's most eligible bachelors are
waiting to meet their mates the mayor is
here parents are here eligible bachelors
and bachelorettes are here
they've even summoned the city's mascots
the great warrior Massa meet sue and his
wife a Honda tada a yo-yo dance today
Alcon katsu in Aoyama llego sanphet
attack a monster - America - what a mess
this is one of many events organized
each year by the Japanese government to
get young people to hook up shack up and
make babies Japan's overall population
is dropping and the government is
panicked without young people to shore
up the country's tax base the coming
decades could see Japan spin into an
economic death spiral Emma a 29 year old
bachelorette traveled two hours from the
city of Tokyo with the hope of meeting
the farm boy of her dreams
yo-yo Jeon woochi sample what I don't
know you wanna
they get bored just keep dust beautiful
just know what it in this car you know
an engine we are giving it a knife you
see this guy
emma has one hour to play the field but
comes up empty-handed so what's next for
you Osaka maybe start from you know
close to where I live like Tokyo maybe
Wow
yeah we'll keep trying yeah why you see
ya
[Music]
Oh